ce qui bonjour Gauthier il s'agit donc
de fournir à l'Ukraine une lettre
concrète et immédiate alors elle est
capitale cette aide concrète et
immédiate dans la mesure où vous savez
d'abord pour des raisons strictement
d'humanité que les Ukrainiens par des
températures qui sont encore inférieures
à celles que nous connaissons ici en
France sont sans chauffage sans
électricité avec des difficultés pour
s'approvisionner en vivre c'est un
véritable calvaire faut bien se rendre
compte que c'est un calvaire à partir de
là on peut aussi imaginer de manière
très
comment dirais-je logique que le soutien
des Ukrainiens à la guerre ou à la
contre guerre à la contre-offensive
menée par les troupes ukrainiennes
pourrait s'effriter et que de ce fait là
il pourrait y avoir justement une sorte
de de délitement de la résolution et de
la détermination ukrainienne à prendre
en charge ce conflit coûte que coûte
donc ça c'est effectivement une mesure
importante à ceci près que vous savez
très bien comme moi que quand on
commence à parler d'humanitaire c'est
qu'on a a commencé à parler d'autre
chose et que le fond de l'affaire n'est
pas là même si encore une fois il est
capital d'aider les ukrainiens et que
probablement quand on place le curseur
vers ce genre de considération encore
une fois aussi importante et capitales
soient-elles c'est qu'on ne va pas
parler du reste et pour autant le reste
et lui alors encore plus capital si je
peux oser cette ce superlatif
justement Gauthier cette conférence
intervient alors qu'Emmanuel Macron
semble isolé par rapport à son
positionnement disons sur cette crise
ukrainienne je pense notamment à ses
propos sur ces fameuses garanties de
sécurité à porter à la Russie qui font
débat pour le moins alors les garanties
de sécurité à la Russie il faut bien
comprendre une chose c'est que il n'y a
de danger sécuritaire pour la Russie que
dans l'imagination de Vladimir Poutine
je m'explique si le régime russe était
aujourd'hui une démocratie aurait-il
besoin de s'inventer une menace
obsidionale qui encercle non
aussi le régime russe était une
démocratie comment pourrait-il faire
valoir sa zone d'influence et bien tout
simplement en ayant des idées en créant
par exemple une une assurance retraite
qui ferait tache d'huile dans les pays
autour les pays autour se dirait ben
finalement le grand frère entre
guillemets russes a trouvé une bonne
solution au lieu de ça c'est l'invasion
la torture et les crimes
est-ce que vous voyez autre chose comme
justification
sécuritaire chez Vladimir Poutine que la
volonté d'étouffer la démocratie en
Ukraine et la volonté surtout d'imposer
la méthode impérialiste donc parler de
des impératifs sécuritaires de la Russie
c'est en quelque sorte entérinée et
validé le régime russe comme
autocratique et puis dernier point qui
est important qui est bon qui qui
découle de celui-là c'est l'idée au fond
que en parlant de la reconstruction
comme on va le faire dans un deuxième
volet c'est dire passons pas perte et
profits la victoire ou la défaite de
l'Ukraine projetons-nous dans la
reconstruction quel que soit l'issue de
cette guerre au fond on fait en sorte
que l'Ukraine ne flanche pas
complètement mais on lui donne pas les
moyens de gagner et ça c'est un abandon
en race campagne qui non seulement
dommageables et terrible pour l'Ukraine
mais pour le reste aussi parce que
Poutine pourra bomber le torse en disant
finalement je fais tout ce que j'ai fait
on maintient pas rigueur on dit qu'on va
reconstruire vraiment au ciel je peux
reconstruire l'Ukraine voilà le cynisme
de la chose au travers encore une fois
d'une opération militaire parfaitement
justifiée merci beaucoup Gauthier pour
cet éclairage